[Música]
el secretario de estado de eeuu anthony
blinken acusó al gobierno de china de
fomentar ciertas condiciones que
facilitan ciberataques para sus propios
beneficios entre éstos el ataque
realizado contra microsoft el pasado mes
de marzo blinken anunció repercusiones
contra el país asiático
ariel henry será el nuevo primer
ministro de haití y encabezará el
próximo gobierno de ese país caribeño
henri había sido elegido por el
fallecido presidente joven el mois un
día antes de ser asesinado pero no había
sido investido de manera oficial el
nuevo premier reemplaza a clottey josep
que asumirá la cartera de exteriores
y con motivo del pronto inicio de los
juegos olímpicos' tokio 2020 les traemos
una serie de reportajes especiales sobre
los nuevos deportes olímpicos en esta
primera entrega hablaremos del surf cuál
es su historia y cómo los 40
participantes debutantes sortearán las
olas japonesas para alcanzar el oro
muy buenas tardes bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por acompañarnos a esta
hora vamos a comenzar en eeuu el
secretario de estado de ese país anthony
blinken acusó al gobierno de china de
promover condiciones que facilitan los
ciberataques y acciones criminales en
otros países para su propio beneficio
financiero a través de un comunicado
blink quien hizo las acusaciones a las
que se unieron también la unión europea
la otan y otros cinco países que
coincidieron en afirmar que varios
piratas financieros apoyados por china
son los responsables de ciberataques a
nivel global entre ellos el ataque a la
compañía microsoft el pasado mes de
marzo el secretario blinken añadió que
habrá consecuencias contra el 'china por
estas acciones que calificó de
irresponsables también el presidente
estadounidense joe biden se refirió a
estos señalamientos escuchemos
tendría un informe mañana en la mañana
un informe detallado según tengo
entendido es que el gobierno chino a
diferencia del gobierno ruso no está
haciendo esto por sí solo
protegiendo a aquellos que lo están
haciendo erwin una investigación
internacional reveló el supuesto
espionaje a periodistas activistas
políticos y también defensores de
derechos humanos con el software israelí
pega sus denuncias o denunciando que fue
utilizado para facilitar la comisión de
violaciones de derechos humanos a gran
escala en todo el planeta
pegasus fue inicialmente diseñado para
investigar a criminales y también a
terroristas pero en esta ocasión fue
usado para interceptar unas cincuenta
mil líneas telefónicas alrededor del
mundo de personas que fueron
identificadas como objetos de vigilancia
en la investigación participaron 80
periodistas 17 medios de comunicación en
10 países diferentes bajo coordinación
the forbidden stories una organización
con sede en parís en francia que también
tuvo el apoyo de amnistía internacional
desde bruselas la unión europea allí
reiteraron la necesidad de mantener la
libertad de prensa
but if it is the case sí es verdad es
completamente inaceptable y contra
cualquier tipo de reglas game en ixcán
dofus we have and your kim hyunjoon en
la unión europea en lo que respecta a la
libertad de los medios de comunicación
tenemos la libertad de prensa que es uno
de los valores centrales del bloque es
completamente inaceptable si este fuera
el caso y se complique next septiembre
facebook be de case aquí el henry es el
nuevo primer ministro de haití
encabezará el próximo gobierno de ese
país caribeño tras la renuncia de
claudio sep que asumirá la cartera de
relaciones exteriores estos cambios
llegan tras el magnicidio del presidente
joven el movice el pasado 7 de julio y
luego de que varios diplomáticos también
la onu y algunos gobiernos de diferentes
países no respaldarán el gobierno
interino de joseph y pidieran a henry
que asumiera el liderazgo del gobierno
el fallecido presidente moi sabía ya ha
designado a henri tienes un
neurocirujano de 71 años como primer
ministro justamente un día antes de ser
asesinado y no había sido investido de
manera oficial
también desde la casa blanca hubo
reacciones sobre este tema escuchemos
no hemos recibido una notificación
oficial a través de nuestra embajada
pero saludamos los reportes de que los
actores políticos haitianos están
trabajando juntos para determinar el
camino a seguir en chica de yemen
cambiamos de tema el gobierno del reino
unido reiteró su reconocimiento al líder
opositor juan guaidó como presidente de
venezuela esta medida está destinada a
eliminar una demanda interpuesta por el
banco central de venezuela respaldando a
nicolás maduro para repatriar casi mil
millones de dólares de reservas de oro
que venezuela tiene guardados en
diferentes bancos en la ciudad de
londres los representantes legales tanto
de maduro como de huairou visitaron
precisamente el tribunal supremo del
reino unido para una audiencia que busca
poner fin a esta disputa por cerca del
15% de las reservas de divisas que tiene
el país suramericano
el futuro de venezuela se juega dentro y
fuera de sus fronteras este lunes
comienza una vista pública en la corte
suprema británica para dirimir quién
tiene la legitimidad para reclamar las
reservas de oro venezolano que alberga
el banco de inglaterra el banco central
de venezuela abajo a la junta rectora
designada por maduro quiere recuperar en
torno a mil millones de dólares en oro
aproximadamente el 15 por ciento de las
reservas de oro del país el problema
radica en quién es el presidente
legítimo ante la justicia británica el
pasado octubre el tribunal de
apelaciones británico falló en contra de
wide hoy la junta designada por él para
dirigir el banco central de venezuela
según el tribunal el gobierno británico
no reconocía de forma inequívoca al
opositor como presidente este lunes el
gobierno de reino unido- reiteró su
postura de reconocer a juan guaidó como
presidente legítimo del país
latinoamericano
el gobierno del reino unido- tiene
derecho a decidir a quien reconocer como
jefe legítimo de un estado extranjero el
reino unido- reconoce a juan guaidó como
presidente de venezuela y en
consecuencia es el único individual que
se le reconoce
autoridad para actuar en nombre de
venezuela como su jefe de estado según
el equipo jurídico de wide o el gobierno
utilizará el oro para despojar al país
de sus riquezas a favor de la corrupción
el banco central de venezuela afirma sin
embargo que es necesario para paliar la
crisis económica y sanitaria ante las
acusaciones opositoras el gobierno pide
que los recursos los gestione el
programa de las naciones unidas para el
desarrollo etiopía enunció que comenzó
el segundo proceso de llenado de su
controvertida represa del renacimiento
en el río nilo un proyecto rechazado por
egipto y sudán según el gobierno de
addis abeba este proyecto es crucial
para el desarrollo económico y para
proporcionar energía a este país
africano
sudán y egipto han mostrado su
preocupación por la construcción de esta
presa debido al temor a un posible
descenso en el nivel del caudal del río
que es fundamental para sus respectivas
economías
y esta semana con motivo del inicio de
los juegos olímpicos de tokio 2020
france24 les trae una serie de
reportajes especiales sobre las nuevas
disciplinas que ya alcanzaron la
categoría de deporte olímpico en este
episodio hablaremos del surf cuál es su
historia y cómo serán las competencias
en las olas japonesas para esos 40
participantes en este deporte
[Música]
aquí el mar impone sus reglas o mejor
sus olas si una ola es alta se puede
sortear en su interior si es enrollada
hay que hacer figuras y los surfistas
tienen que explorar la ola de manera
óptima los criterios de evaluación son
bastante precisos el término de
radicalidad potencia desenvoltura y
también de innovación sumando todo esto
se da una nota sobre vida de los 25
jueces se evalúan el desempeño el
surfista con la mejor nota será campeón
en tokio las olas enrolladas necesitan
un entrenamiento especial son sobre todo
las pequeñas que hay que trabajar de
manera distinta trabajar el tono
muscular se necesita hacer dieta para
estar lo más ligero que se pueda y así
ir lo más rápido posible sobre las olas
pequeñas y los juegos será el instinto
marino el que marque la diferencia
es la capacidad en un ambiente tan
aleatorio como será en japon de
identificar el lugar correcto
la opción antes de ir al agua de
mantenerse y de tratar de tomar las
mejores olas
[Música]
pararse sobre una tabla en el mar está
práctica nació en la polinesia mucho
antes de la época moderna cuando los
eeuu anexaron el archipiélago de hawai
el surf comenzó a difundirse en el mundo
entero aunque comenzó como un pasatiempo
se profesionalizó en los años 90
tener al surf por primera vez en unos
juegos olímpicos ya de por sí la
consagración de nuestro deporte porque
aquí se le está viendo como una
verdadera práctica deportiva y no como
un juego de la clase para ella en
monterrey es un deporte extremo hay
muchísimo peligro y tiene una parte
táctica muy importante creo que si a
alguien le gusta el deporte seguramente
le gustará el surf se pasan bien
microsoft para los juegos olímpicos de
2024 el surf volverá a su cuna en
polinesia en esa esquina del mundo los
artistas retar a nate a guapo la mítica
ola de tahití
es todo por el momento aquí en france24
puedes seguir con nuestra programación o
con más noticias en france24 punto con
buenas tardes
[Música]